[Musique]
c'est une opportunité d'affaires nous faisons du
porte-à-porte nous vendons des magazines que
nous explorons comme l'Amérique nous faisons la fête venez
avec nous tu vas manquer à
quelqu'un pas vraiment d'accord bon tu es embauché
est-elle d'accord oh ouais tu dois garder
apporter des prières j'ai essayé d'
être chrétien mais je peux voir que le diable a
une emprise sur vous deux le diable a une
emprise sur votre fille où
allez-vous gagner de l'
argent ici faire de l'argent
comme une fille était amusant hé  MJ x pas la fête -
ouais fais jouer les clés ou plaisante grand ouvert
as-tu des rêves
c'est comme si le futur prouve toujours me demander si
tu penses que tu es spécial dans ta salle de bain
tu ne veux pas dire
qu'aucun mari
[Musique] a
peur bang
[Musique  ]
c'est une opportunité commerciale que nous explorons
comme l'Amérique nous faisons la fête venez avec nous
Merci 4200 obtenez les clés bleues sautez le
Clark jusqu'à l'horloge
avez-vous une chance de penser que vous êtes
spécial
[Musique]